bitcoin's price has been crashing it
went all the way down to thirty thousand
dollars there's people freaking out
everyone's running and screaming there's
lots of fear in the market and one of
the rumors one of the conspiracy
theories is that michael saylor and
microstrategy who hold over 120 000
bitcoin they're gonna get liquidated
they'll have to sell their bitcoin and
they go into the market and sell
billions and billions of dollars of
bitcoin we're all screwed the price is
going to zero well of course that's all
nonsense what are people talking about
so in order to clear up all the rumors
and to address the conspiracy theories
michael saylor he took to twitter and he
went ahead and he showed exactly what's
going to happen
ultimately michael saylor's got a lot of
bitcoin and it doesn't have that much
debt and so naturally bitcoin's price
would have to go all the way down to
under 3
600
before microstrategy would get
liquidated microstrategy and michael
saylor they're not a systemic risk
they're not going to get margin called
they have so much bitcoin they can
continue to post more and more and more
collateral if bitcoin goes under three
thousand six hundred dollars you ain't
gonna be worried about micro strategy
and michael saylor you're gonna be
worried about what the hell went wrong
and so this is a great lesson of the
internet just because somebody says
something on the internet it doesn't
make it true and otherwise every time
you hear a rumor go figure out the facts
go find the source information and go do
the math for yourself there's a perfect
example michael sailor ain't gonna get
liquidated at twenty-five 000 he's not
going to create some death spiral in the
price of bitcoin of course he has a ton
of bitcoin do the math for yourself
think for yourself and stop listening to
random accounts on the internet who are
just fear-mongering and they're trying
to create all sorts of fun ultimately
bitcoin doesn't give a [ __ ] but michael
saylor microstrategy me you or anybody
else it continues to produce block after
block after block of transactions and
the price is determined by supply and
demand
and all i see
is that long-term holders continue to
hold bitcoin and buy more of it and so
naturally
i don't think you're gonna see
all of the promises all of the dreams of
the bears come true bitcoin is a beast
it's a durable asset and i tend to think
it's going to be just fine so relax
breathe take a deep breath life is good
and bitcoin
will survive this too shall pass my
friends
michael sailor ain't getting liquidated
stop listening to people on the internet